it can be hard keeping track of what's
going on in the mcu
and what's coming up in the near future
but there are big things on the horizon
for your favorite superheroes
here's a handy list of every upcoming
movie in marvel's phase 4.
we've been promised that a black widow
would happen for years and soon scarlett
johansson will reprise the role of super
spy natasha romanov
for what will likely be the last time
the prequel is set in the period between
civil war and infinity war but it will
also flash back to romano's childhood
before she entered the red room
training program and was later recruited
by shield starring alongside johansson
will be florence pugh
as elena belova a fellow red room
graduate who has raised as a sister to
natasha
and will potentially be taking over the
black widow mantle
black widow will also star rachel vice
as molina vostokov
another red room operative who appears
to have helped recruit the young natasha
also starring as david harbour who will
portray the red guardian
russia's answer to captain america it's
not yet known he'll be playing
taskmaster
whose photographic reflexes allow him to
perfectly mimic the fighting style of
anyone he faces
however we do know that the film is
coming to both theatres and disney plus
premiere access on july 9th
meaning disney plus subscribers can
watch the film at home for an additional
thirty dollars chiang chi in the legend
of the ten rings is the starring vehicle
for the mcu's first asian hero
the titular xiangchi the master of kung
fu that's incredibly exciting news
but we're also pretty psyched to see the
supremely skilled fighter
facing off against the real mandarin the
classic iron man villain who'd been
cruelly teased with ben kingsley's
imposter trevor slattery
in iron man 3. destin daniel cretan is
directing
and chinese canadian actor si moo liu
will be holding down the title role
who just so happens to be the finest
unarmed combatant in existence
according to xiang chi's trailer the
film will find our hero being drawn into
the world of the ten rings the terrorist
organization that kidnapped tony stark
and iron man and was mentioned by darren
cross as a potential buyer for the
yellowjacket technology in ant-man it
seems their incredibly intimidating boss
wenwoo
happens to be shang chi's dad and the
notorious mandarin
and he wants his son to take his place
in the notorious terror group as you
might assume
chiang chi has a few things to say and
people to punch about that
we can't wait to see all the action go
down on september 3rd 2021
if you want to know more about the
cosmic side of the mcu then get psyched
for eternals the titular heroes at the
center of the film are a group of
superpowered beings created eons ago by
the celestials in order to defend the
earth from the evil deviants the film
will be directed by chloe zhao
who made history in 2021 as the first
woman of colour
and only the second woman ever to win an
oscar for best director
for her work on nomadland which also
nabbed the academy award for best
picture
with such an epic story and acclaimed
filmmaker it's only fitting that
eternals would have a similarly
impressive cast eternals will start game
of thrones richard madden as icarus
a first generation eternal and the
leader of the flicks team of heroes
alongside him will be angelina jolie as
cena gemma chan as cersei and barry
kyogen as druik
plus kumel nanjiani appears as kingo an
eternal who's become a major bollywood
star
lauren ridloff will star as a
gender-swapped version of mccurry
an expert engineer speedster and the
first death hero in the mcu
brian tyree henry will appear as fastos
the mcu's first openly gay hero
and a master weapons maker who prefers
not to fight salma hayek will play a
gender-swapped ajak who's the spiritual
leader of the group
and the lodges lea mchugh will be
playing the tricks to sprite
we can expect to see it all unfold on
screen on november 5th
2021 when jk simmons reprised his role
as j
jonah jameson from sam raimi's
spider-man trilogy during the end
credits of spider-man far from home
we probably should have suspected that
something strange was a foot in the mcu
cash money for a picture of spider-man
he doesn't want to be famous
and i'll make him infamous now things
are said to get even odder
in october 2020 it was announced that
jamie foxx would be returning as electro
his character from the amazing
spider-man 2
then a few weeks later marvel dropped
the bombshell that the movie would
feature an appearance by alfred molina
as dark ark from remy's spider-man 2.
there are even credible rumors that
charlie cox will be making an appearance
as matt murdock daredevil from his
netflix series while far from home
teased the multiverse that ultimately
turned out to be a ruse perpetuated by
mysterio
the inclusion of such an impressive
roster of characters from various marvel
but not
mtu franchises seems to nod to the real
thing we'll learn exactly how all of the
various spider verses fit together
when spider-man no way home hits
theaters december 17
2021 the sequel to 2016's doctor strange
has been in development since before
that flick even hit theatres and in 2019
we learned that the film would be titled
dr strange and the multiverse of madness
the sequel will co-star elizabeth olsen
as wanda maximoff and it will be
directly influenced by the weird events
of one division
joining the cast of doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness is babysitters
club star zochi gomez
and america chavez also known in the
comics as miss america
rounding out the cast will be returning
dr strange actors rachel mcadams as dr
christine palmer benedict wang as the
sorcerer wonk and chewie tell ego forest
mordo
who served as strangest friend and ally
before taking a dark turn at the end of
the first film
spider-man trilogy director sam raimi
will be stepping in for original
director scott derrickson
and reuniting with composer danny elfman
who's taking over scoring duties from
doctor strange composer
michael jacquino given his fantastic
character arc over his last several
appearances
it came as little surprise that thor
would be the first avenger to receive a
fourth solo film
thor ragnarok's tiger ytt will be
returning to direct but 2019 san diego
comic-con offered some even more
shocking details
about the upcoming flick specifically
the thor sequel will see the return of
natalie portman's jane foster
who will follow in her character's
recent comic book footsteps by picking
up mjolnir to become thor herself
tessa thompson will also return as
valkyrie and kevin feige has confirmed
that this time around
it will be made explicit that the
character is bisexual a first for a
major character in an mcu film
serving as the antagonist for love and
thunder will be christian bale as gore
the god butcher
a character who in the comics was
obsessed with killing gods and absorbing
their power how it will all come
together and whether the title points to
a complicated love triangle or something
else will all be revealed when thor love
and thunder hits theaters
on may 6th 2022 after the tremendous
success of 2018's black panther
the first mtu film to earn an oscar
nomination for best picture
and the first mcu film to win an oscar a
sequel seemed like a foregone conclusion
sure enough in the fall of 2018 the
hollywood reporter announced that black
panther 2 was officially happening with
original writer director ryan coogler
returning to right and direct the sequel
and celebrated star chadwick boseman
expected to reprise the role as t'challa
the king of the fictional country of
wakanda tragically in august of 2020
bozeman passed away following a
four-year struggle with cancer
the news came as a shock to bozeman's
fans and colleagues alike as the actor
had kept his condition and treatment
quiet
even as he continued to work while
marvel declined to comment on the future
of black panther immediately following
bozeman's death
allowing his castmates and fans time to
grieve now by panther wakanda forever is
moving forward with a release date of
july 8th
2022 executive producer victroya alonso
has confirmed that wakanda forever will
not be using a digital double to stand
in for bozeman
leading many to speculate that his
on-screen sister shuri
may take up the black panther mantle as
she does in the comics
is there any member of a royal blood
who wishes to challenge for the throne
while marvel is keeping quiet so far
about what carol danvers will be up to
the next time we see her we do know that
she won't be alone
the film that was originally presented
as a sequel to 2019's captain marvel was
revealed on may 3rd
2021 to actually be a team-up feature
titled the marvels brie larson will be
returning as carol danvers aka captain
marvel
but joining her this time around would
be tiona paris he was introduced in one
division as a grown-up version of monica
rambo
and iman valani he will be appearing in
her own disney plus series as carol
danvers number one fangirl
kamala khan aka ms marvel monica rambo
was first introduced in the 1990s
timeline of captain marvel
as a young girl played by akira akbar in
one division the adult moniker plays a
key role as a sword agent determined to
get to the bottom
of wonder's mysterious hex who winds up
gaining superpowers in the process
the title of the marvel suggests that
the film will see her fully embracing
her identity
as a superhero which has seen her take
on a number of names in the comics
including photon spectrum and even
captain marvel
meanwhile in the comics kamala khan is
an inhuman who originally models her
superhero persona after her idol carol
danvers and
later adopts the name ms marvel as a
tribute to her inspiration
although no plot details have yet been
revealed for the marvels the title
suggests that the three heroes will be
featured with equal prominence in the
film
rather the monaco and kamala serving as
supporting players in a carol danvers
solo venture
as was initially assumed zaway ashton
will co-star as the films as yet a named
villain
marvels will be soaring into theaters on
november 11th
2022 after playing a key role in saving
the entire universe during the events of
avengers end game
and mama returned for a third headlining
feature returning to the director's
chair is peyton reed
of the three-quarter read promised the
third unmanned movie is going to be a
much bigger more sprawling movie than
the first two
it's going to have a very different
visual template returning for ant-man
and the wasp quantum mania
a franchise stars paul rudder scott lang
and evangeline lilly as hogue van dyne
along with hope's father and scott's
mentor hank pym
and the long-lost wife he recently
rescued from the quantum realm janet van
dyne
joining the cast will be katherine
nudeson as a teenage version of scott's
daughter
cassie who was briefly played by emma
fuhrman in avengers endgame
in the comics cassie becomes a superhero
stature one of the early members of the
young avengers
plus lovecraft country star jonathan
mages will be playing iconic marvel
baddie kang the conqueror
this could potentially kick off the
start of a longer rock in the mcu for
mages since kang is one of marvel's most
notorious and powerful villains
expect to see our heroes battle their
new foe on february 17
2023 in july of 2018 the news broke that
james gunn
writer and director of the guardians of
the galaxy franchise have been let go
from the third installment over a series
of very old
and admittedly highly inappropriate
tweets that have been dug up by
conservative pundits
guardians fans and the cast of the film
were up in arms but a silver lining came
in august when it was announced that
gun's completed script would at least be
used the search was on for a new
director
a search that continued right up until
march of 2019 when disney put an end to
the whole kerfuffle by rehiring gunn the
nearly year-long
impasse has had the effect of delaying
volume 3 for a bit
as it didn't take gun long after his
canning to find another gig
one at rival studio warner brothers
writing and directing the suicide squad
for dc
marvel studios agreed to wait patiently
until gun's work on that film was
finished but now that gun is done
working on that dc project he can turn
his eyes back on the ragtag heroes of
the mcu
as it now stands guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 will be showing up for action on
may 5th
2023 and as for the plot we assume it
will have something to do with the
guardians
searching for gamora check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
mcu movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you